o la espera un segundo por favor
bienvenido al renderizado mi nombre es
christopher depp y soy un investigador
de pixar el renderizado es la última
fase de la línea de producción
cinematográfica que lleva nuestras
películas de esto a esto el renderizado
es donde el mundo que hemos creado en el
espacio virtual en tres dimensiones de
la computadora se hace finalmente una
realidad como una serie de imágenes
bidimensionales perfectamente
renderizadas y luego proyectadas una
tras otra tras otra durante 96 minutos
convirtiéndose así en nuestra película
el renderizado es un proceso
increíblemente laborioso todo un
centrado en responder una sencilla
pregunta la pregunta es de qué color es
este pixel y luego este píxel y luego
este pincel y este píxel y hasta ahí
parece lo suficientemente sencillo me
refiero a que el logo es
azul entonces el pixel será azul cierto
bueno no exactamente un píxel es una
pequeña porción de la imagen final actúa
como una pequeña ventana hacia el mundo
virtual 3d para entender de qué color
debería ser tenemos que averiguar qué
parte de la imagen estamos viendo a
través de esa ventana entonces
traducimos la pregunta de qué color es
este pixel a las matemáticas y a esta
ecuación le llamamos la ecuación de
renderizado la cual es una descripción
matemática de cómo rebotan la luz en el
ambiente se que dijimos color y esta
ecuación es sobre luz pero existe una
buena razón para ello el color es luz
solo que luz de diferentes longitudes de
onda
por lo tanto cuando planteamos la
pregunta de qué color es este pixel
realmente estamos preguntando qué luz
atraviesa este píxel dirigiéndose hacia
la cámara la solución de la ecuación
será la respuesta a nuestra pregunta
este pixel es morado para renderizar una
película como op
tenemos que preguntar de qué color es
este pixel miles y miles de millones de
veces pero al igual que sucede con cada
parte de este proceso cada pequeño
cálculo no es difícil de realizar más
bien es la capa tras capa de cálculos lo
que lo hace complejo pero también es lo
que hace posible traer algo tan hermoso
como esto a la pantalla